je me trouvais ici sur ces parcelles
mais à 80 km à l'est de l'endroit où
nous l'avons trouvé à temps non non non
non on revient est ce que tu sais où
sont tes parents ta famille ils devaient
être partie pique-niquer ou faire du
camping il s'éloigne et il a dû s'égarer
il vit dans les bois
seul libre comme l'air un petit garçon
comme tu les aimes
resté combien de temps six ans personne
ne peut survivre dans une forêt tout
seul pendant six ans tulard à jéliote
c'est qu'ils les lionnes
et
il faut que je vais y retourner
il adore cache pas
lyautey une personne n'en ait tiré un
tradi c'est quoi rendre sa scène draghi
tu n'as plus à cacher les people tu peux
vivre avec nous cette créature est
dangereuse bien polytechnique
mais quand vous venir te chercher
tu ne sais pas de quoi cette créature
est capable
allons chasser
tu es très courageux tu le sais
certainement garçon le plus courageux
que j'aie jamais rencontré
appel à toutes les unités nous roulent
en direction de mila mulroney à la
poursuite au ballon c'est pas mal on ne
parle pas de tracts dans un message
radio
ats
l'humoriste
fr oui
blatter s'est aussi ben oui au sérieux
meetic est pas qu est ce qu un temps
non das
le
oui
le fait est une autre